My name is
Jean Claude Van Damme
I use to be super famous
Jane
It's your favorite client
I'm back
JC
When I told you I was back, I did not mean JCVD
I meant Johnson
This isn't a game
I sent you out there before you were ready. People died
No one's going to die
Except for all the people I'm going to kill
Well JC good news, the mission and the cover job are yours
But you're going up against blood thirsty, drug runners.
Yeah, I hope you're ready.
Action.
Daddy's home
There's a new man of the house
Cut, cut
I'm so, so sorry man
Johnson meet Louis
Is he qualified?
Vanessa. What's going on?
I'm in.  You got move.  Now!
Jean Claude Van Damme?   Yeah
No, no, no.  One at a time, or you'll run into each other.  Could get confusing.  Go
He's not ready.  You need to pull him. He's going to get someone killed. He's going to get himself killed.
What scene is this?  What are we doing right now?
Are we rolling?  Roll!
Louis, I need your help. With what?
You couldn't find a better car?  Hey, I want to buy drugs
Race me for it
I learned a trick a long time ago.
When one sense is gone
The others heighten
I don't think that applies to vision
When driving
Sorry
Classic Johnson